now the last few weeks have seen some
pretty bitter rows between different
parts of the uk as local coronavirus
restrictions have been imposed
the most notable of course was the very
public argument between boris johnson
and greater manchester's mayor andy
burnham about to reflect on a turbulent
few weeks for the united or maybe dis
united kingdom
we're joined by the former northern
powerhouse minister jake berry thank you
very much for
uh being with us i mean it's not new is
it to be talking about the north south
divide but at the minute
it feels a bit more pronounced doesn't
it well absolutely this
coronavirus has put the north south
divide in
sort of real focus hasn't it where we
see large areas the north having been
locked down
since the end or since the beginning of
august and that's why
we form this new group in parliament to
make sure that we can drive forward
the economy and the ambitions of people
who live in the north of england
forest johnson of course fought the last
election saying that he wanted to level
up
the country but do you feel that some of
the political
decisions over covet have been taken
really with london in mind rather than
the northern cities and north of england
when to impose restrictions
when to lift restrictions and when to
give financial support
think initially they were i think that's
changed with the three-tiered system
based on local data
i absolutely support that and want to
see the government
doing more and working more with local
areas but what
i want to really focus on isn't just how
we tackle this virus
but it's what we do next because of
course large areas of the north
in fact now most of the north i think
are in tier three
i want to see a clear route out of tier
3
a northern covid recovery plan and lots
of the infrastructure projects that we
committed to at the last general
election need to be reprofiled
into the first part of this parliament
to ensure that the northern economy
can recover uh for after this terrible
disease
you say you want to see a clear root out
of tier three
at the same time that we know what the
root out three is don't we
it's when the data on covid starts
going in the right direction rather than
the wrong direction and at the minute
if you're looking at cases if you're
looking at testing positivity
if you're looking at hospitalizations
all the data's going in the wrong
direction isn't it
what i want to do is for the government
to level with
people to provide the data in an
understandable way to
set targets for the public and for
businesses as well
to move out of tier three if you visit
any scouter or church all around the
country you'll see the
thermometer on the wall saying we're a
couple hundred quid away from our
roof replacement fund or whatever it may
be we need to treat people
the same about coronavirus if we expect
everyone to play their part
make them part of the conversation
targeters help us
get out of these terribly tight
restrictions that i say for many areas
of the north we've been in
since august you wrote this week that
the government's communications and
leadership
has been sorely missing in these
high-stakes negotiations what do you
make of the way the government handled
those negotiations with andy burnham in
particular
well first of all i think the government
uh doesn't have anyone
uh who has a strong relationship with
the northern mayors in the way that we
did when
i was northern powers minister or simon
clark was the local growth minister
so i think they started at a
disadvantage secondly
uh as we later found out the approach
around money was
formulaic it was a set amount of cash
that these areas were getting
so frankly to have a week's worth of
debate about what many areas were
getting was a bit of a waste of time
because
we should really have been focusing on
what we can do to clamp down
on this disease and i just hope that
going forward we've learned
that we need to treat our northern
leaders and northern mayors as a
partnership of equals
and uh just really concentrate on
bringing them with us
in our battle against covington and do
you think the government really
understands
some of the problems facing the north
some of the challenges
facing the north well i think they do
and you could see from the compelling
argument the prime minister made in the
2019 conservative party manifesto
but he really got under the skin of
these northern towns he was able to find
and focus on what really mattered to
them this group we've formed of 80
northern conservative mps we'll be
drawing our numbers from that
more conservative mps than i think we've
ever had before in the north
is going to work with government to
deliver that compelling view because
many of these communities who voted
conservative for the first time
ever in their electoral history electing
a conservative mp
want to show that things have really
changed where they live
and we can't let kovid knock us off the
course of delivering the northern
powerhouse and levelling up our nation
and just finally um we've been talking a
lot on the program about free school
meals whether they should be provided
over the holidays as well as in term
time and
berno jenkins said that the government's
misjudged or misunderstood the mood of
the country on that
and what's your take well my take is
that there's
a differing approach being set out by
the conservative and labor party one
believes that the right way of dealing
with it is provide vouchers during the
holidays the conservative party
actually in agreement with your previous
guest has said well we should increase
universal credit
child tax credit and also give over 60
million pounds to local authorities
who of course are providing meals to
pupils in the term time
to really focus down on tackling that i
actually think that the debate has been
very unhelpful to have people shouting
scum at each other
in the house of commons doesn't move
this forward this is a systemic issue
and where we will ultimately get to is a
blend of both of those positions
so to take either one of those as a
point of view does not mean that you
want
children to go hungry that is a complete
lie that is being
put out there by opponents of the
government's position
it actually means that there's a
differential approach and ultimately
where we will end up i guess just before
the christmas holidays later this year
will be a mix of the two
but no one wants to see any child go
hungry in this country and that is what
all parties i think
are trying to achieve